our own cooking confidence coach nanny
bubby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment i'm so glad you're back in
studio and i'm so glad to be working
with you this is going to be so much fun
we're going to learn how to make
homemade pumpkin puree right from real
pumpkins but before i do that you
probably think i'm hocking halloween but
i'm really not what i really am here to
talk about is thanksgiving and here's
the reason why is these cute little
tiger pumpkins these cute little pie
pumpkins and these other larger tiger
pumpkins are going to be off the grocery
shelves by november 2nd oh so if you're
wanting to make homemade pumpkin puree
which we're doing today if you want to
make soup bowls out of these little
tiger pumpkins if you want to make a
cranberry bowl out of this i'm telling
you right now get to the grocery store
get them before halloween because they
will be gone i always learn stuff from
you and we haven't even started i didn't
know these were called tiger pumpkins
first of all and i didn't even think
about using those as serving dishes
that's brilliant okay the other thing
we're doing today is we're gonna take
this canned pumpkin that everybody uses
and we're gonna put it to the test okay
right you're gonna make something we're
making a fresh pumpkin puree which it's
so easy i don't know why we ever bought
it in a can it's the truth so ready
these are called pie pumpkins do not use
jack-o'-lantern pumpkins use your pie
pumpkins okay and i'm just going to show
you how easy it is first you're going to
cut off the top
okay
then you're going to put it flat down on
that flat
part and then you're going to just slice
it right down
whoop now do it then what you're going
to do is you're going to take your
grapefruit spoon which you have right
here okay and you're going to go right
into your little compost
basket and you're just going to pull it
out get all that get it all out that
happens in seconds and what i'm going to
do that is a very small pie pumpkin this
is a large one could be up to three to
five pounds so whichever size you can
find find it so here's the next thing
very easy we're going to take the
pumpkin that you're
scooping out and this is how you're
going to make it you're just going to
take it
spray it with avocado oil
very quickly okay just you see that
right over the top
put it upside down just like that
into the oven 400 degrees for about 25
to 35 minutes you're going to test it by
taking your little paring knife
and putting it right into the skin like
that if it goes all the way in you know
that you're done okay
i put that in for about 25 to 35 minutes
okay all right perfect then what we have
is these are not as warm as they were of
course when you take them out of the
oven you want to let them cool but two
things i want to show you look at this
caramelization along the edges do you
see that do you see how beautiful that
is that is what you want and you would
not believe how easy it is to pull this
skin off which we don't have time but i
will show you that another time
and then what i'm going to do very
quickly is i'm just going to cut this
very easily into cubes and go into the
um
into the food processor so that you can
have a taste test and put old lippies to
the test should i say that name i guess
i shouldn't i i really am impressed with
this caramelization you this is only
from the avocado avocado oil on
parchment paper and you could you can
see how easy it is let me start at the
stem and this skin just pulls look at
that pulls right off you see that so i'm
just going to reach in and grab it off
and i'm going to just pull like this
wash clean hands chef's best tools and
you said again do not use
jack-o'-lantern pumpkin no it tastes
like raw vegetables right and also when
you're using those tiger pumpkins what
you want for bowls you just want to bake
them for about 10 to 15 minutes so that
you get rid of the raw taste so okay
into the food processor there we go just
throwing it in
i mean i would
even eat it just like this
well here take a bite is it good yes my
hands are good okay
there we go all the way in
that's really good isn't it this is
fresh pumpkin do you see how easy that
was
so easy okay top on okay
so while i'm worrying this taste that
canned pumpkin just take okay
[Music]
okay so this is what i take
when i taste it i taste aluminum
i taste sodium yeah it's like okay sugar
okay ready okay i'm gonna get a fresh
spoon here oh you got a spoon for me i
do i have a spoon for you yes because
there are no spoons here all right
here we go
all right let's take what does that have
in it
it's just fresh so easy it's so easy oh
my gosh so good fantastic that's it buy
your pumpkins now before the end and we
say together on the count of three one
two three go out and do you know what it
is spread love light butter you'll get
it next time all right check out daddy
bobby's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com she
is the best we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment
kendall
smith
butter
[Laughter]